hey youtubers is Charlie so we finally
got spider-man confirmed for infinity
war so I'll explain that but I wanted to
do a list for the characters that we did
know about so this is going to be top 50
there are a lot of characters new
rounded the spider-man giveaway starts
now - all you have to do to enter is be
a subscriber and leave a comment on this
video
announce winners at the end be sure to
click that Bell to enable alerts so you
don't miss anything so the big news is
that Tom Holland confirmed that he was
going to be an infinity war he'd been
left off the list that everybody had
been posting so there was a question
like hey maybe they won't include him
but I don't think any of us believe that
I mean you got to put spider-man in
infinity war so top 50 characters that
are going to be an infinity war I tried
to group some of these together starting
with the really big ones that are brand
new and then the supporting characters
the classic roster so number 50 s
starting to list op spider-man Tom
Hollands said this is part of the
interview that he gave it's they who
convinced Marvel talking about Robert
Downey jr. and Chris Evans
to be sure that I was the right person
before you entrust three films over the
next four years including Avengers
infinity war so that's a bit of a broken
sentence but it's a translation of the
Italian interview where he basically
says that Robert Downey jr. and Chris
Evans really went to bat for him because
Spiderman was going to be so important
for the next three movies the three
films that he's referring to are Captain
America Civil War spider-man homecoming
in Avengers infinity war but we know
that he's actually signed on for more
spider-man sequels since then but he's
just talking about those three films in
this interview next on the list Doctor
Strange we all know that he is now the
de facto magic user that they'll go to
for help
he knows a little about the infinity
gems he is very well-read so he's
already helping Thor with his Ragnarok
problem so he's seen Dormammu he's been
to other dimensions he wields one of the
infinity gems he's going to be super
important to the Avengers then there's
Wong who comes hand in hand with Doctor
Strange next one is Baron Mordo not
really a main character of infinity war
but so big that you have to touch base
with him characters that you'll see in
the film that they'll touch on that will
be big
Easter eggs but might not necessarily be
on screen as much as the classic
Avengers the bigger actors so next one
is Captain Marvel big introduction this
is supposed to be her introduction
spider-man style although a lot of her
backstory is going to be left for the
Captain Marvel solo film then there's
the Winter Soldier he is in a deep
freeze right now so we'll have to thaw
him out because he's every bit as
capable as Captain America when Thanos
comes calling you need as much help as
possible Nick Fury is back and if you're
wondering why he hasn't been in the last
couple Marvel films it's mostly because
of contractual disputes with Samuel
Jackson he's a very expensive person
they chose to spend their money hiring
other actors to do other characters they
felt were more important to the story
next one is Loki just like Doctor
Strange also has a lot of information on
fan OHS that he can help everyone with
definitely has to come to terms with the
idea that he double-crossed Thanos and
he's going to try and survive that man
of the hour is Thanos if you haven't
read the Infinity Gauntlet or infinity
quest storyline from the comics it's
basically him assembling the gems
forming the gauntlet and then erasing
half of all life in the universe in the
Avengers all the heroes trying to fix
that so he's probably the most important
character in that movie so numbers 41
through 36 is basically his forces the
black order the Shotaro that are left
over in any other space army that he
brings to bear so he does have a lot of
followers we met one before the other
was a member of the Black Order that was
killed by Ronan back during the first
guardians of the galaxy film so we'll
probably find out who is helping him
because he won't be all by himself Peter
Dinklage from Game of Thrones was
actually just announced as I was making
this list so I got to include him just
in time Rob Liefeld was like the first
person to say he's pip who's an
important figure with Adam warlock in
the Infinity Gauntlet storyline but I
don't actually think that Peter Dinklage
will play pip he just supposed to be an
important character in both of the next
Avengers sequels speaking of the
Guardians pretty much every main
Guardian character is coming including
star-lord who hasn't returned to Earth
in a long time
I'm so it'll be the first time that he's
actually interacted with other humans in
a long long time Gamora and nebula
daughters of Thanos family reunion
rocket Groot who may or may not still be
baby Groot it depends on how big he
grows by the end of the guardians film
but for most of that film he's supposed
to stay that same size and then of
course Drax
but we haven't heard anything about
mantas new big character in guardians to
showing up so I'm not expecting her in
the film but then here we get to like
the supporting characters we haven't
seen in a while
so Pepper Potts will touch on with her
she won't be a big part of the film but
she is currently running stark tech for
Tony while he runs The Avengers or tries
to run The Avengers
Jane Foster Betty Ross is supposed to
come back there's a rumor that Liv Tyler
will come back even though they've
recast the Holt
since the last time she played that
character then there's Thunderbolt Ross
who's the defense secretary very
important government figure Sharon
Carter who is very close to Captain
America's character now Coulson is
finally rumored to be coming back Ghost
Rider is a really cool character that's
supposed to have at least a brief
appearance he's too cool for you to
leave out and he's just as powerful as
the Hulk if not more powerful it was
actually dr. strange who theorized
during World War Hulk the Ghost Rider
was one of the few entities that was
around and available that could take
down world breaker hook Maria Hill also
rumored to appear on may is a little
more certain just coming hand-in-hand
with Peter Parker Hank Pym because of
ant-man and the wasp
speaking of which ant-man and the wasp
ant-man is a very important Avenger
already the wasp is going to be a very
important character but she's not going
to have a relatively big appearance to
the second Avengers film in the ant-man
in the wasp solo movie but she will have
a presence during infinity war even
though Evangeline Lilly the actress has
said that she won't be wearing the wasp
costume until the ant-man in the wasp
movie the other new main characters of
course black panther very important
Everett Ross which is a Black Panther
character we'll see him again during the
Black Panther movie vision in Scarlet
Witch who also kind of come hand in hand
now war machine who is slowly recovering
from his accident Valkyrie who's another
Thor character that we haven't met yet
but she's really important there will be
a couple of characters from each of the
Avengers films to make guest appearances
Valkyrie is just like the new biggest
character that we're gonna meet then the
classic roster
Captain America who still doesn't have
the shield but I think we all expect him
to pick the shield back up during
infinity war just because the threat is
so great the Hulk post Ragnarok who will
have gone through almost an entire film
in Hulk form so banner will be much more
in tune with the big green guy they'll
have a much more straightforward
agreement between the two of them reborn
Thor baptized by fire now it won't be
like rune King Thor but he will be more
actualized more powerful more assured of
himself much more prepared to become
king after Odin a much less cynical
version of Iron Man thanks to Peter
Parker's influence I feel like his
excitement is going to be infectious
he will help Ironman loosen up before
infinity war we have Hawkeye and Black
Widow and then rounding out the top five
is the defenders characters they've said
a lot about them not being in the film
the way people expected so don't be
surprised if they're like really big
Easter eggs and they're not getting a
lot of screen time but daredevil Jessica
Jones iron fist Luke Cage in the
Punisher the list of 50 is really just
preliminary they said there's going to
be 66 plus characters so we can amend
this later on when we confirm other
people but a lot of those extra
characters are really just background
people people whose names that you'll
see on lists won't actually have like
functional lines or dialogue in the
movie so when they say 66 plus
characters are in the film really
there's going to be a fraction of that
that you'll see on screen at any given
time so don't worry it's just when they
say there's a lot of characters in the
film it sounds like it's going to be a
mess it will not be a mess don't worry
but if there's any spider-man or
infinity war videos that you guys want
me to do just let me know in the
comments or for the other Marvel films
I'll say congratulations to this week's
spider-man giveaway winner Joshua stuff
went a's you went a $20.00 comixology
gift card be sure to private message me
on the back end
and also I can get your contact details
there was a new round that started in
this video they just announced a whole
bunch of Star Wars Episode 8 plot
teasers so I'll be doing a video for
that next there's a whole bunch of
awesome stuff happening this week a
whole bunch of stuff is coming back
really soon it's going to be great well
you guys wait for that to post you can
click here to catch up on aces of she'll
learn about the Doctor Strange Darkhold
stuff that they've been doing and you
can click here to learn about why
everyone's freaking out about Batman and
Justice League thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight